this was the moment the u.s said it hit
a popular mobilization force's base
near iraq's al-qaim border crossing with
syria the air strikes happened in the
early hours of monday
targeting both sides of the crossing on
the iraqi side
a base use for drone attacks was hit a
statement from the u.s department of
defense
said the targets were selected because
these facilities are utilized
by iran-backed militias that are engaged
in unmanned aerial vehicle attacks
against u.s personnel and facilities in
iraq
the iraqi military spokesman issued a
strong statement
we condemn the usa attack that targeted
a site last night
on the iraqi syrian border which
represents a blatant and unacceptable
violation
of iraqi sovereignty and iraqi national
security
in accordance with all international
conventions
two groups backed by iran were targeted
kitab hezbollah and kitab
saeed ashahada reaction from the groups
was swift
have actually reacted very strongly
promising an open war
against uh u.s targets within
iraq itself now the real concern here is
one simply
of escalation the iranians also reacted
the us still continues the wrong path in
the region what we see today is not only
the sanctions but also following the
wrong policies in previous
administrations
in regard with actions they carry out in
the region
some analysts suggest iraq must have
been consulted before the strike
this is only the second time that
president biden has used military force
as was mentioned earlier the first
strike was almost exactly four months
ago the end of
the end of february i also think it's
significant that he attacked
iranian-backed forces at the same time
the negotiations are going on
what level of coordination remains
unclear
the popular mobilization forces comes
under control of the iraqi government
it was only a few days ago prime
minister mustapha al-qardami praised the
palau military group in public
however there's long been some concern
about who certain groups within the
umbrella organization
actually answer to whether it's iran or
iraq
it's clear that the popular mobilization
forces are part
of its security structure so in effect
the u.s
bombed an ally but the u.s was clear
that the popular mobilization fighters
had attacked u.s targets and the bombing
was in response to that
and with a response promised by the
group it's likely this will further
divide the u.s and iraq
and opinion on the u.s role in the
country imran khan al jazeera baghdad
let's go to our white house
correspondent kimberly halcott kimberly
good to see you
why did the u.s think these airstrikes
were necessary
right now
well as the pentagon statement has been
very clear
the u.s president joe biden believes
that these strikes are defensive in
nature
and it is important to note that this is
the second time
since the start of the year that this
type of action has been taken
the argument being that these are
attacks on u.s
personnel that are being conducted by
iran-backed militia and as a result the
united states is trying to send a very
clear message that this type of behavior
will not be tolerated it's also
important to note
that this comes at a very delicate time
because of course the united states is
trying very hard
to revive the discussions that have been
ongoing a sixth round
a seventh to be scheduled in vienna to
limit iran's nuclear program
and the feeling is that as
these talks are being conducted it's
important to
send a very clear message to iran where
it stands what the united states will
tolerate and will not tolerate
so this is something that comes at a
delicate time a fragile time
but the united states feeling that it
needs to send a message of force
and there's been some reaction as well
from people within biden's
own party what have they been saying
yeah the president's own democratic
party some top senators as well as
members of congress chris murphy in the
u.s senate ilhan omar
in the house of representatives not
happy
about the conduct by the white house
that it has once again acted
without the authorization of congress
and the fear is in all of this
is not only the impact on civilian
casualties potentially but also
the fact that this would fall under
potentially
jurisdiction that requires authorization
under war powers
and that has not been sought so the
united states
uh looking very much as if it is taking
an aggressive posture and the u.s
congress
demanding answers so we're watching very
carefully not only to see
what the briefings will be that will
take place on capitol hill and whether
or not that will satisfy members of
congress
but also we're watching carefully at the
upcoming white house press briefing
to see what the white house press
secretary has to say and the
justification for this action
many thanks for that white house
correspondent kimberly harkett